damn are really if only on how they go
at that I didn't strive for success I
strive to do something artistically
important I'm of the impression that bad
things are something that really are
important to one's life all the meetings
are rather like painting and you can use
the same tools and work within all the
different mediums
adapting to the idea of being kind of
mainstream I found very difficult indeed
thank god this is visual the
possibilities are almost limitless what
can we do now the work is never finished
now until the viewer contributes himself
I don't know why but ever since I was
really young I thought I did never have
a problem making money whatever I did as
I get older I get more and more selfish
about what it is that I want to do that
I find satisfying
he was an English singer-songwriter
artist painter record producer and actor
he was a popular music icon for over
four decades his flamboyant appearance
was a cornerstone of his image he's
David Bowie and here is top ten rules
for success when I was 18 or 19 I think
I had a whole set of people that I
looked up to I don't think I ever I
think you only influence to a certain
extent I think what happens is that you
look at somebody and think that maybe
something you had as a small seed in
your own mind you see maybe that person
has extended that or gone quite a long
way with what you think you might like
to do anything yeah that person's doing
what I really like to do and that's what
could happen that's what I can do with
what I've got and that's so that kind of
influence are I'm proud to if I have
been influential on on people that in
that way that's really good because
there's a certain kind of regret that
when you haven't been adventurous with
your ideas there's when you get into a
later life and you haven't even tried to
do some of the things that you really
wanted to do and you can look back and
say damn I really if only I'd had a go
at that you know things might have been
different or I would at least know if I
could do it or not and the people I
looked up to when I was a kid like
William Burroughs and like Little
Richard and like John Lennon that they
did it you know and
I thought well I'm gonna absolute fool
of myself but I'm gonna you know go for
it to strive for success in 2:16 you
achieved success and now you sit in your
green chair looking back on it all yeah
and what do you say not true
I didn't strive for success I strive to
do something artistically important and
success over here I believe is very much
in the kind of material world so can I
just say that before we start I wanted
to do something artistically valid you
can learn from tragedy I think you can
I'm not sure that a bad experiences in
America they're so King for you not to
have bad experience they spend half
their lives trying to avoid bad things
happening to them I'm of the impression
that bad things are something that
really are important to one's life and
bad experiences and not necessarily a
bad experience it is a gun from Bad
expert they do yeah that it's a you can
I don't think they should be looked at
negatively at all if I'm writing and
recording I find I don't need to paint
but if I'm not doing very well and I
can't write then it was just there's a
kind of a block or a blank and I just I
revert to painting and that kind of
opens up like a watershed of ideas and
associations and things so it's kind of
it's almost a device to help me often
find that one medium helps the other you
know I mean because I always go back to
that analogy that that all they're all
all the mediums are rather like painting
and you can use the same tools and work
within all the different mediums and and
so I can understand what I'm trying to
say often by painting it first and I
think now I know what I'm trying to
write and I can go back and and both
musically and lyrically yeah adapting to
the idea of being kind of mainstream I
found very difficult indeed
but that looking at it in a fairly sober
light I felt that I could deal with it
you know and I just couldn't I was so
beat by the whole three-ring circus
thing about it and trying to reach a
wider and wider audience you know
without actual any kind of feelings of
artistic passion at all I didn't really
believe in the material
doing and indeed some of it was very
good material but I just had lost the
belief in myself as a creative artist
and I got introduced to Reeves Gabrels
as a guitar player and just a good guy
that I met and he just very simply said
you've just got to stop doing this you
know there's no way out just stop doing
it do what you like doing I said but you
don't understand so yes I to understand
I've read all the books and that was it
really and I just stopped doing it you
know and I formed Tim machine with the
really quite clumsy idea that I could
just disappear into abandon anima Slee I
found my exit from all that mainstream
stuff through Tim Machine I mean that
was my sort of my holy grail at the time
it was ah this is the truth I don't find
it very exciting anymore German I think
it's got to get a lot more dangerous
again well working on it yeah I think
it's probably good to step back from
one's work for a while and and try
something totally new I think it give it
does revitalize your original enthusiasm
and that's what it has been like for me
over the last few years and now that I
have ventured back into something that's
very personalized it does seem that
there's been a lot brewing and it is
just thank god this is visual whatever I
go on the road with again will have to
be something that I have the utmost
belief in which is a great way to start
again for me for the 90s for my age
there's peculiar crossroads in rock now
with so many of us approaching forties
and will shortly be in their 50s so if
this is kind of a brave new world for us
so that the the possibilities are almost
limitless what can we do now do we do
what is the usual predictable thing
which is not is Kara's his revered
repertoire within throughout his career
but as we were doing new things when we
first started we should also continue to
do new things now so I thought for some
people what I might consider rubbish
might actually have a real strong
trigger to somebody else the way they
look at it and what they need from it
you know an artist these days especially
since Marcel Duchamp poem about the work
is only one aspect
Tovah the work is never finished now
until the viewer contributes himself the
art is always only half finished it's
never completed until the audience for
it first then it's the combination of
the interpretation of the audience and
the Asiya worked itself it's that gray
area in the middle is about what the
work is about okay I don't know why but
ever since I was really young I thought
I didn't never have a problem making
money whatever I did so really it was a
choice of what was I going to do for it
and I just had a passionate affair with
music it is a very amorous affair with
music as I get older I get more and more
selfish about what it is that I want to
do that I find satisfying and it's
definitely how one should spend one's
life is is because you know if you make
yourself happy a little bit of that
sunshine can spread on to others thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know which of the
top ten clips that you saw meant the
most to you had the biggest impact leave
it in the comments below and I'm going
to join in the discussion and if there's
a famous entrepreneur that you want to
feature in a future video leave that
becoming too low - thank you guys for
watching continue to believe I will see
you soon